so I walked down the aisle stood in
front of the boss and I held out my hand
he took a knife cut my finger some blood
dropped on the floor this is a blood
hole and then I cupped my hands he took
a picture of a Catholic saint put it in
my hands and lifted a flame and it
burned quickly it was merely symbolic it
didn't hurt and he said tonight Michael
Francis you are born again into a new
life into cosmonautra violate what you
know about this life betray your
brothers and you will die and burn in
hell like the saint is burning in your
hands do you accept yes I do and at that
point you're a made man
[Music]
welcome to episode 163 of the Michaela
Peterson podcast I'm Michaela Peterson
in this episode I spoke with Michael
Francis Michael's a former mobster and
leading member of the Colombo crime
family after being part of the mob in a
very serious way for more than 20 years
he decided to completely change his life
in a large part because of Christianity
his story is pretty amazing some people
have lives that sound like made up
stories it's a crazy world out there I
was very excited to speak to him I have
been for a while he's the author of a
number of books like Mafia democracy
which we discussed and he works as a
public speaker with the goal of steering
people away from participating in
organized crime Michael and I discussed
the ritual of becoming a made member in
the mob Michael's wife bringing him into
Christianity the growing mistrust of
government today the Acts of the
Apostles and Jesus and more before we
get started this episode of the podcast
is sponsored by rabbit air you can see
it glowing in the background right
there
there it is for people who suffer from
them living with allergies can range
from mild to miserable and in rare cases
like mine allergies can make your face
look like you weigh 50 pounds more than
you do thankfully rabbit air is HEPA air
purifiers filter out 99.97 of the
allergens and pollutants from the air
since the beginning of the Fall allergy
season it's the perfect time to get one
for your home office space or your
bedroom or your kids bedrooms or your
living room or your kitchen a lot of
people suffer from allergies without
realizing it so if you're someone who
wakes up with a stuffy nose or you're
congested allergies can look like a cold
as well so if you're someone who gets a
cold and then gets bronchitis it could
be because of allergies given we breathe
in nearly 2 000 gallons of air cleaning
the air in your house can really reduce
immune responses to allergens they've
really helped me and I like how they
sound and look you can get your rabbit
air air purifier today by going to
rabbitair.com to see their models or
call them 24 7 to speak to a rapid our
consultant that's
r-a-b-b-i-t-a-i-r.com I hope you enjoy
this episode
[Music]
how have you been thank you so much for
coming on oh my pleasure I I've been
good you know I've been busy
um things have recovered quite a bit
since uh we had that downtime in the
pandemic but uh everything's been good
before we get started for anyone who
doesn't know who you are do you think
you could give a brief background about
who you are and we'll get into this what
you've done and what you currently do
um Michael Francis grew up in New York
my dad was the under boss of the Colombo
family one of the five New York mafia
cousin and Austria families so I grew up
in that environment he was a very very
high profile figure he was kind of like
the John Gotti of his day in terms of
media attention law enforcement
attention
so I grew up around that my dad was
indicted several times went to trial
four times eventually was convicted on a
major racketeering case excuse me a
major uh and went to prison uh for 50
years
and I was a pre-med student in Hofstra
University at the time of his uh
incarceration and Joe Colombo who was
the boss of my family back then kind of
took me under his wing and threw a
series of events I decided to leave
school and try to help my dad get out of
prison and as a result my dad proposed
me for membership in that life I became
a made member of that life took the oath
in 1975
and spent about 20 years in that life
first as a soldier which is the initial
rank when you you come into the life and
then as a captain Capital regime
and um I was a major Target of law
enforcement myself you know mainly
because of my dad's name and started
that way but I was arrested 18 times I
was indicted seven times I had two
Federal racketeering cases one brought
on by Rudy Giuliani
went to trial five times was acquitted
in five cases but then took a 10-year uh
plea for a 10-year prison sentence a 15
million dollar restitution
um and just before that I met a young
woman who is now my wife of 37 years and
basically it was because of meeting her
and her faith that you know caused me to
try to walk away from that life
and that's what I did back in 1995 after
serving my prison sentence and
um since then I've been a speaker an
author been involved in the film
industry to some degree
and uh here I am some 20 odd years to be
alive and free and you know living a a
fairly normal life so that's that's the
basic thumbnail sketch okay this is
great you you've had such an interesting
life
um is it have you had the experience
going through these experiences in your
life that it's surreal or because you
grew up in this did it kind of feel
normal yeah early on it was normal for
me
um because I don't remember anything but
my dad in that way from the time I was
you know able to start to realize what
life was all about so you know growing
up like that was normal growing up for
me hating hating the police hating law
enforcement hating the government was
normal because I viewed them as enemies
to my family uh you know I always heard
chatter in the house and how bad you
know law enforcement could be I loved
and idolized my dad so anybody that was
you know trying to hurt him uh became my
enemy so it was normal you know growing
up I mean I I looked at it that way
okay okay that makes sense
um what about stress wise I mean being
indicted all the time and having cops
there or after you constantly were you
guys in a kind of hyper-stressed
position you know Michaela it's funny
you asked that I went to uh about a year
ago I went to the doctor and uh had a
little bit of a condition that on your
face where you start to lose your beard
just a little bit in spots
and they say normally it's caused by
stress so the doctor said to me do you
have a lot of stress well I don't know I
mean I don't know what stress is I just
lived this way my whole life you know
with watching out and being careful and
and you know trying not to make any
mistakes so it was just such a normal
part of my life I don't think that I
viewed it any differently even till now
I mean things that are major to some
other people are are nothing to me uh
because of my you know my history in
that regard so but you know in that life
it's it's very difficult to navigate the
life
on its own
but when you have that additional
um you know problem of law enforcement
constantly on you like they were with me
it becomes that much more difficult so I
was always kind of walking a tightrope
you know my whole 20 years in that life
yeah wow
um and I I looked up how old you were
before the podcast are you 71 I am okay
because it doesn't look you don't look
like you've been stressed out for your
whole life I was um just in the other
room with my husband and I was like he
was like he's 71. I was like no no you
look good well I can tell you I can tell
you this my dad passed away at 103. okay
it was one of six uh was one of 19 yeah
he was one of the United to their late
80s 90s uh he outlived them all but
um so we have some good genes in the
family but you know I mean I don't feel
any different than I felt 30 40 years
ago so I don't I don't know maybe I'm
just fortunate in that regard and you
know I try to keep myself in good shape
and
it's it's a number maybe it's the the
high stress life was doing something for
you living that long wow I might have
worked in Reverse yeah that's funny
um okay I do want to get into your
wife's faith and your faith at some
point in this episode because I think
last time we spoke I talked a little bit
about my experience because I grew up
you know with my dad teaching me the
biblical stories and the psychological
significance but I didn't believe in God
that's for sure I wanted to but I didn't
um so you said you met your wife and it
was kind of her faith that
changed your life can you get into that
a little bit Yeah my wife was a devout
Christian when I met her but she was 20
years old and
um it had an impact on me in that not
that I was buying into it I grew up
Catholic but for me Catholic school you
know Catholicism was like a subject in
school I went to Catholic school and so
I wasn't really engaged in in my faith I
understood that I had to practice the
religion but I wasn't engaged in my
faith I did believe in God but that was
about it
um so when I met my wife and I saw how
devout she was and then take that a step
further meeting her her mother my
mother-in-law all about Jesus I mean she
was the most godly woman I ever met in
my life very simple woman
um and had a a beautiful way of
expressing her faith she was very
um you know outgoing about it but
I respected their belief it wasn't that
I was buying into it I respected their
belief and it was really at that point
that I realized you know they didn't
really know who I was they grew up out
here in California where I am now in
Anaheim and I'm from New York so they
didn't really know much about me or the
mafia or anything like that but it was
saying to myself these two women they're
a direct contradiction to everything I'm
about and where they really know who I
am how is this going to work out you
know
um it's not going to work out so
wanting to have her in my life was
starting was what made me interested in
learning about my faith
so that's how she influenced me
but really what happened
um when I went to prison the second time
I was child I did five years I was out
on parole for 13 months and then they
violated my parole and it's a whole
story behind that the government was
upset with me because I wasn't
cooperating
and they put me in solitary and I was in
solitary for 29 months and seven days
yeah it was a long stretch Michaela and
after that experience that we were not
meant to be solo preachers we were meant
to be social oh and a lot of guys at
night yeah when those lights went out
man you heard a lot of moaning and
groaning a lot of people do not do well
and I understand uh but it was really
during that experience that I grew my
faith because I dove into my Bible if
you see my prison Bible there's more of
my notes on there that there was a
scripture and I had my wife send me
several hundred books on all different
faiths because I really was in a search
for the truth because I thought I would
never come out of prison the government
had told me that I'm going to die in
jail that I'll never see the light of
day again so I was worried about
eternity is this real where am I going
to end up
and so that's what really motivated me
to learn about my faith and you know an
old due respect everybody else I came
out of there believing a hundred percent
in Christianity
through my research
you know that's it wasn't anything
um surreal I didn't get visited by God
in the cell
uh there was no no moments like
Supernatural moments for me uh it was
just my research and then the experience
that I've had ever since not only in my
life but in no and and so what God has
done in their life so that's how this
came about with me wow I can't imagine
I can't imagine solitary confinement
like that for that period of time
yeah that's hard Michaela you know I'm
so totally against that for young people
that that are in prison you know unless
they're a danger to others and or danger
to themselves it's just uh it's cruel
and unusual there's no question about it
yeah it's surprising that that's
surprising that that's still used really
because that seems like it's like akin
to torture
so you're not supposed to torture people
so it's strange that that's used
okay um the prison system uh yeah you
know they they do what they feel they
need to do you know you you mentioned
something that I'm not familiar with
when you were describing uh
uh like when I first asked you who you
were and what it is you do you said
something you became a made member can
you describe what a made member is
it made members when you take an oath
and you officially become a member of
that life and it is a very uh solemn
ceremony
and leading up to that you have to prove
your worth or prove your value and prove
that you have the privilege in their
view the honor to become a member and
when that happens it happens in a very
solemn ceremony
and you know I I underwent that ceremony
um on Halloween night in 1975. and
basically took an oath and I can
describe it for you I mean you know
there were six of us that took the oath
that night and we walked into a room it
was midnight we walked into a room
individually the boss of the family was
seated at like the head of a horseshoe
configuration in the under Boston the
consul area which are two official
positions were to his left and right and
then all the other captains consulgaris
were alone I mean a couple of James were
alongside of them
so I walked down the aisle stood in
front of the boss and I held out my hand
he took a knife cut my finger some blood
dropped on the floor this is a Blood
Oath and then I cupped my hands he took
a picture of a Catholic saint put it in
my hands and lifted a flame
and it burned quickly it was yeah it was
merely symbolic it didn't hurt and he
said tonight Michael Francis you are
born again into a new life into Cosmo
Nostra violate what you know about this
life betray your brothers and you will
die and burn in hell like the saint is
burning in your hands do you accept yes
I do and at that point you're a made man
wow okay that's slightly different than
any initiation ceremonies I've heard
that a normal normal person goes through
wow that's quite movie-like it's quite
abnormal
well it is you know and it's uh you know
they wanted you to understand the
seriousness of what you're getting
involved in so it's uh it's very solemn
and it's taken very seriously you know
the Mob Life of close enough it's not
people think it's a business not a
business it's a way of life it's a whole
mind subculture from everything else
that exists so you got to be in it you
know body mind and solo you don't you
don't survive in that life and um you
know so the fact that I was able to walk
away
um is is really
it doesn't often happen you know unless
unless people become informants and
cooperate with the government and go
into a witness protection program it's
very hard to get away from that life
yeah so how did you manage to do that
well you know for me there's two two
reasons for that you know the um
the overall reason is I believe God had
a different plan and a purpose for my
life and that's certainly played out
over the past 20 some odd years
um but the Practical reason for that is
you know God never throws us into the
fire without preparation and I I knew
that life extremely well
so
when I walked away I knew what I would
face you know one of the horrors of that
life Michaela and I you know again hate
to be offensive but I'm just being
honest is that you make a mistake your
best friend walks you into a room and
you don't walk it out again
and you know unfortunately through my 20
years I know people that have
experienced that and so when I walked
away I said okay then I welcomed me into
a room they're going to have to come and
get me
so I moved out to California
you know it's it's one thing to walk
somebody and to pull out you know cross
country to try to hurt you and then get
away with it I was extremely
um
disciplined in that I changed my whole
lifestyle I didn't go into any
nightclubs where people know who I am
and you know I walk out in a parking lot
and you know I'm in trouble
uh I didn't walk my dog every morning at
7 00 a.m I didn't go to the same
restaurant every Tuesday I didn't create
patterns in my life so if people were
looking for me they'd know where to find
me I was very discreet in that regard
early on and you know long story short
and they they did put a contract on my
life and I did have trouble in that repo
Garden I had one or two close calls but
bottom line is I just outlasted
everybody
I mean everybody I know is either dead
or in prison for the rest of their life
and you know at the end of the day I
didn't put people in prison I didn't
turn against them in that way I just
left
so you know over a period of years
people said ah you know we'll leave them
alone he didn't hurt anybody
and that was the end of that so I think
God protected me in all of this I have
to believe that yeah well
sounds like it it's what it sounds like
to me
wow
um
okay let me see
I have I have a lot of things I wanted
to cover oh one thing I was interested
in
for decisions made so let's say business
decisions made in the mafia does that
decision come from the top down or is
there a negotiation people take part of
well it depends on what you know what
we're talking about in business
you know the way fortunate in that I
knew how to use that life to benefit me
in business and had a lot of success as
a result both legally and illegally
um
the biggest thing I did you know I had a
divisor scheme to defraud the government
out of tax on every gallon of gasoline
it would be nice if I was in that
business right now I'd be making more
money than I made back then but
um because the taxes are a lot more but
um it was my scheme so to speak so but
anytime you do something in that life
you have to put it on record with your
boss so he has to know what you're doing
and so you know when I came across this
deal I brought it into my boss at the
time and I told him what I was doing and
you know I paid up to the family also I
gave them you know part of the proceeds
of what I was earning and you have to do
that that's how the family survives
but when I had a legal business which I
had many I had two car agencies I had a
Film Production Company some restaurants
that was mine I didn't have to give
anything to anybody with that so
um but you know the the boss in the
hierarchy of the family they do get
involved in a lot of the business
dealings because they need to know
what's going on and how risky it is I
suppose yeah you know and and sometimes
they'll say no we don't want you
involved in that like you know in our
our life during my era in that life we
were not allowed to deal with drugs
um couldn't deal with drugs drugs was
off limits I know guys have gotten
serious trouble for dealing with drugs
um you know if they violated the rules
um and that comes from the top you know
and you can't buy it when they're no
discussion yeah that makes sense
um how much money were you making from
this
this I guess gas scam you could call it
well
yes I ran that operation for about eight
years I had the Russian Mobsters from
Brighton Beach in Brooklyn that were
working with me they had a little past
operation
and yeah and we were very close and over
a period of eight years we were selling
a half a billion gallons of gas a month
and we were taking down 30 40 cents a
gallon we we're bringing in between
eight and ten million dollars a week at
that time and when was that so you know
that's what that's what the operation
would that's what the operation was
grossing back then
wow what when what year was that uh this
was from about 79 through 85. okay wow
that is a lot of money and so how much
and let me know if I'm asking anything I
shouldn't be asking but how much of that
did you keep well you know I mean there
was a million and a half two million
dollars a week that was coming into my
pocket wow I had to I had to pay up yeah
uh my boss the family was getting uh
about two million dollars a week also
um because we didn't have a lot of
expenses quite honestly you know we just
the way the the way we ran the operation
I mean you know I I had my own jet plane
at that time I had a helicopter I had
you know three houses in three different
states in the country uh so I mean we
had all the little bells and whistles
that that a little bit more comfortable
uh but I was putting a lot of money away
um no question wow I didn't realize that
you could have kind of different Mafia
groups work together I'm not that I know
anything about this topic but you said
you worked with a Russian mafia is that
is that common for different I guess
groups to work together
I mean you can I mean we you know we
oftentimes worked with a group of Irish
mob guys called The Westies they were in
Manhattan they were based in Manhattan
we worked with them at times the Russian
mob you know not many people work with
them but I happen to get along with them
and we had a very good relationship for
a number of years
but it's not really common but it does
happen it depends upon the situation do
you know anything about how it's
structured now like is is the mafia
still I guess as powerful as it was back
then now and just not talked about as
much it's you know you know a lot of
people say that you know it was John
Gotti that destroyed the mob because he
was so flashy and and uh you know
outspoken and people like to point
fingers in different ways but what
destroyed the mob was the RICO Act the
racketeering laws
um we didn't we didn't understand it we
didn't keep up with it and it gave the
government such a
um and it devastated my former life you
know throughout the mid 80s and you got
to give Giuliani credit for that because
he was the first one that used the
racketeering laws effectively and he set
the pace and so he put so many guys away
uh he took away so much power that we
had through the unions
um he stripped us of all of that and he
made so many people turn informant and
as a result it's not as powerful today
not nearly as powerful it was through my
era but it's still there it's not going
away it still exists the same structure
is in place uh I think guys have gotten
smart and they're a lot more low-key you
don't see the John Gotti's anymore out
there and flashy uh because you can't
last in that life when you when you're
like that
um but it's not going away in my
lifetime I can tell you that if you're
listening to this you are probably some
of the most well-informed and least
paranoid people on the planet but are
you too nonchalant about your safety
what about your data do you have the
same mindset when it comes to keeping
your internet connection secure it's not
paranoia if everyone's really out to get
you the main thing about using a VPN is
if you're downloading content and you
don't want to be caught you don't have
to be paranoid that you'll go to jail
because of some archaic law when doing
so just use nordvpn your internet
service provider also can apparently
sell your data to advertisers for a
profit all while forfeiting the idea
that people like you have a right to own
their online information you can defend
your online privacy by grabbing your
Nord VPN deal today over at nordvpn.com
tmpp or use promo code tmpp for 61 off
their Premium plan and their free
anti-malware feature all with nordvpn's
30-day money-back guarantee
yeah yeah and I suppose I mean I don't
know what the effects of the last couple
of years have done but I know just the
general public has less trust in the
government so I would assume you know
the more restrictive of a society the
more likely people are to do things
illegally especially if you get forced
into doing things that you think are
reasonable and then they turn illegal
that'd make the line a little blurry
well you know it's funny Michaela I you
know I speak in church quite a bit and
there was some times when I'll make this
statement and
the pasture like cringes and I said
listen I have no moral issue I'm being
very honest I have no moral issue with
stealing tax money from the government
because I believe I can do a lot better
with it than they do they steal our
money as far as I'm concerned and wasted
on wasteful things and and enrich
themselves
um I said but I won't do it because I'm
not going to go back to jail and I'm I'm
not going to have you know uh sin in
that regard whether it is a sin or not I
really don't know but
um and it has to like cringes but people
in the in the Church Clap for me they
stand up and they give me an ovation
when they say that that's how how much
distrust they have in the government
today
it's evident yeah
um you know you couldn't have said that
you couldn't have said that 30 40 years
ago people would look at you like you
said something wrong but now they
applaud you for saying that yeah yeah
it's pretty strange time when when I
first met my husband
um he's kind of what turned me to the
Christian faith as well and he's
very Christian
and uh he I I was being skeptical and he
he's a pretty like disagreeable
skeptical person but I was like oh yeah
I don't really trust you know people are
just people right so you put people in
positions of power like doctors say or
people in the government but they're
still just people it was like I don't I
don't trust I would say if if someone's
in a position of authority I'm less
likely to trust them for whatever reason
and so when we first met we kind of had
discussions about who was trustworthy
and who isn't trustworthy and I was like
I don't trust the government right now
like I don't really trust the medical
system I don't really trust the
government and anyway he's come around
but I think that is a change in the
recent years like you said 30 years ago
things would probably have been
different significantly different it's
gotten bad in the last five years really
yes
absolutely it's
uh you know I I don't you don't want to
get me started on that I mean I just
wrote a book called homophobia democracy
and
you know Michaela it's it's amazing how
mob-like our government is acting in so
many different ways and you know since I
still have that mentality and I've had
that experience I see how Machiavelli
and our government is being and it's
it's frightful it really is it's scary
and the government overreach and the
things that are happening now I'm I'm
really concerned about the future of our
country I really am this is not to be
America that I grew up in or that my my
family believed in when I should not my
dad but everybody else but you know it's
frightening it really is what I see
going on here on a daily basis
yeah yeah
um I agree I just did an episode with my
dad and um this guy named Vivek
ramaswamy who who wrote a book called
woke Inc and we talked about esgs I
don't know if you know about esgs you
might but it's it stands for environment
social governance scores and so CEOs of
major major corporations some of the
really big ones like BlackRock have got
together and they decided that the
companies under them should have ESG
scores so they're rating these like
capitalist companies on how well they do
supporting the environment or how well
they do supporting social causes right
and
it kind of undermines the entire system
that America was built in just
capitalism because you can trust a CEO
to
increase the wealth of their company
right and increase the amount of money
their shareholders have and be greedy in
that way but when they start
implementing policies that infect the
environment or affect the environment
things like that the country starts
getting a little bit strange we're
releasing that episode today but it's
something worth looking into esgs
because I think a lot of the um
political unrest that's
caused by a number of reasons right now
is also caused by this kind of top-down
implementation of esgs in these giant
corporations
esgs I'll send you I'll send you a link
on I think you should know I'd love to
see that I'd love to see it really yeah
um
okay one one question so if you've kind
of I mean you you grew up in this but if
you've kind of crossed the line and
decided okay the government's the
government taking tax money
um isn't isn't good and if the
government's after your family and
police are after your family how do you
define what's morally acceptable and
what's not morally acceptable if it's
not by what the law says
well you know that's uh
you know that that's an age-rel question
and somebody had said to me one time you
know Michael you have no moral issue
with paying taxes but Jesus said you
know render therefore to seizure what
are Caesars and to God the things that
are God's and I said yes he did say that
I said but understand the environment in
which Jesus said that
he didn't believe that the Romans should
be over taxing the people he wasn't
saying that's a good thing and that's
what the government should be doing
but you know they tried to put Jesus on
the spot when he was in a crowd of
people and if he would have said no
don't pay the government or the Romans
ago he would have put people in Jeopardy
so what he said is listen you got to
obey the law I'm not saying it's right
I'm not saying it's not sinful what the
Romans are doing taking advantage of you
but he was he outsmarted the people that
asked him that question so
um do I think it's morally wrong to
you don't want to hide money from the
government that I think that they're
misusing and that they're using against
us
you know I don't think it's sinful I
don't
um and and I'm trying not trying to
justify because I'm not doing that now
and I'm not justifying what I did back
then because when I did it back then I
was a criminal I did it with Criminal
Intent I wasn't being you know Robin
Hood or I wasn't trying to share it with
others you know and your intent means
everything so back then it was Criminal
Intent I was enriching myself and the
people around us
but um so at that point it was sinful
but if I were to do that now and say you
know the government is overreaching I
know for a fact
um that this is wasteful money I know
that for a fact that they're taking
advantage of people that are trying to
put food on their table and pay their
mortgage and and so on and so forth so I
I don't believe it would be sinful if I
had the right intent in what I was going
to do with that with that money yeah so
judge them I don't know if I explain it
explain that right but yeah
um kale I mean I wrote this chapter in
my book that
if you see why why is it that government
workers
I mean government uh elected officials
go in with blue-collar income and lives
and come out as multi-millionaires
because they use the system to enrich
themselves and that's not what this
system was built upon they were supposed
to be public servants doing the work for
the people that put them in office
but you know you get people like Nancy
Pelosi I'm sorry that you know she's
enriched herself to the tune of several
hundred million dollars using her
position to enrich herself to me that's
sinful that's not what this system is
set up for
um so I look at it is I'm exposing this
I'm letting people know this is what's
happening now I don't want an
Insurrection I don't want a revolution
what I'm saying is the way you make
people pay for this you hold them
accountable at the voting booths you
know and and I'll tell you this in your
own life if your husband will use that
or my wife lies to me once well okay
they lie to me a second time you start
to get a little bit more irritated a
third time a fourth time it becomes a
pattern you're not going to accept it
you're not going to accept it it's not a
healthy relationship well we put our
people in office they lie to us
constantly constantly make promises they
don't keep reverse themselves you know
and we look at this no it's not politics
that's lying and we shouldn't allow them
to do that so what do you do you vote
them out we still do have power in
numbers here in this country and that's
that's the whole reason I wrote the book
the whole reason I'm so irritated with
this and you know people say well
Michael why are you so why are you so in
tune with this now it's not me I'm 71
years old there's not much more they can
do to me or about me or you know that's
just I'm here now but I have seven
children I have grandchildren and I
concerned about the future of this
country for their benefit and so I'm
trying to sound the alarm so to speak to
let people understand
um what's really going on and some of
the things that I'm seeing now are just
they're so scary I mean the way the
government is using the FBI as a tool
for them yeah that's supposed to be it's
supposed to be an independent agency
that's very very very scary now I will
tell you this I know from past
experience that the FBI overreaches that
they break the law to go after criminals
but maybe maybe Kelly you can justify it
because Mobsters are criminals so hey
you overreach a little bit against the
mobster nobody's going to get upset but
when you start doing that against
legitimate people because remember you
give the government they'll take a yard
they'll take as much as they possibly
can and if they overreach against the
criminal they're overreach against the a
legitimate person too so you have to
keep them in check that's with democracy
that's what a republic is all about we
have to keep them in check and
unfortunately I don't see that happening
now and it's very scary to me
it's also hard to see who's in charge
right now
like who's making the decisions behind
what's going on that scares me
it's like you don't even know what's
happening well it should
it should scare you
um you know and most people and you
don't blame them they're oblivious to
this they don't understand you know
they're being fed information and they
take it for what it's worth but you know
Middle America most people in this
country what are they concerned about
paying their mortgage putting food on
the table they're not they're not paying
attention to the things that are going
on and they don't see it they don't
understand it
they can't blame them
um you know I every once in a while I'll
watch one of these shows where they go
out into the street and they ask people
about things that are going on in
government today and some of the
responses Michaela I don't know if you
ever people are still going on in the
country our world it's it's and they're
voting they're voting I know yeah well
it's
it's a lot easier to I think it's a lot
easier to operate in your life if you
just take some things for granted right
now it's not easier if the things that
you trust start failing around you but
if if you walk around like before I kind
of started questioning everything you
know I had trust in the government doing
what a government is supposed to do and
the medical system doing what a medical
system is supposed to do and then you
don't have to think about those things
you can just say okay those work how
they're supposed to work and you can
focus on other issues in your life but
if you suddenly start thinking about all
those things it's like oh what exactly
is the government and what is it doing
right now and who's in charge and what
are its goals and how is that changing
the shape of the country and then how
are different policies being implemented
how are those affecting me like that
complicates things to a level that makes
it a lot harder to think well I need to
go to work today and just make enough
money so I can eat it's like that's on a
different level exactly no you nailed
yeah you're absolutely right it's just
it's so much information to process it's
uh
it's very difficult it's very difficult
for people to focus on which Search and
say what's really happening here they
don't want to deal with it and I get it
they they put people in office they
expect them to do the right thing and
that's it unfortunately it doesn't
happen that way
um
not not to not to necessarily get into a
Biblical discussion but that that um
verse you talked about that's repay to
Caesar what belongs to Caesar
I also wonder
what he was talking about when he said
repay to Caesar what belongs to Caesar
right because you could say re repay to
the government what belongs to the
government that's not necessarily what
the government is telling you belongs to
them well you know people don't
understand
we're taxed on everything I mean the
food you eat the clothes you buy the car
you drive uh the the the uh the roads
you drive on uh the airline you travel
on everything is taxed you know we
sometimes forget that it's not only
personal income tax or corporate tax
everything is taxed there's nothing
that's tax-free uh in our daily lives so
does the government have the right to
tax everything that we live by
I guess they do they're the government
they're in power they can do it they
make the laws doesn't mean it's morally
now
especially when the money is being
squandered yeah yeah the money is being
used for the right for the right things
well okay we have to support America
this country we have to support it when
if you look at the government waste If
people really focus on it and understood
where their money was going they'd be
outraged Outreach I have a chapter in my
book that talks all about this they'd be
outraged because the billions and
billions of dollars of wasteful spending
uh that that's just done for the benefit
of the people in office
it's it's mind-boggling so what made you
decide specifically to write about what
you wrote about
you know it just it got to a point where
I said I just can't you know I just
can't I have a platform
you know I have a a fairly big following
and I said it's not right for me just to
sit on this I have to make people aware
of it and and again it's really for the
future of my children and grandchildren
that this country is I I think we're on
a a very bad course and I don't know if
it's reversible at this point I really
don't I don't you know biblically are we
getting near the end times uh there's a
lot of you know people always say that
and it could be another Thousand Years
who knows I mean we don't know but it
certainly looks like things are falling
apart here in America I mean the whole
mentality is changing you know people
who now are young people are are
um talking about socialism in a good way
socialism has really I mean real
socialism hasn't worked you know
credibly anywhere in the world but we
were talking about that here in the
United States
um and they're advocating it I mean you
know we have politicians now that are
that are uh avowed socialists and people
are supporting them so I mean it's it's
scary stuff for me and I just figured
hey you know what I have a platform
um uh it's time for me to sound the
alarm and that's what I did
do you do you think um sorry I've talked
to my dad about this too and I was like
things look pretty bad from my point of
view at the moment and I don't know if
it's going to get worse
um or if if people are going to get sick
of it and in maybe a decade things will
turn around because it's gotten worse so
quickly that maybe Society needs time to
catch up to kind of realize what's going
on to fight back against it but I asked
him if it was actually worse than what
he's experienced because he's been alive
during he was very concerned about the
Cold War right and that was definitely
you know America entered danger zone
during that period of time but do you
think from your experience throughout
life politically this is the most
unstable you've seen America
oh absolutely we said you know there was
a time when the Democratic and
Republican parties were not too far
apart
they really weren't they had some
different things you know uh different
ideologies in a little way but you can
have peaceful conversation you can have
intelligent dialogue you know Democrats
and Republicans got along
um I have never seen these countries so
divided I've never seen such vitriols
such hatred such Venom coming out from
one side against the other and it's
starting at the top listen you know I I
I was a supporter of Donald Trump
because I supported his policies and I
took some heat from that people said
well you're a trump lover I said no I'm
just not a trump hater I don't have the
syndrome I supported his policies
because I felt they were good for
America I said listen I don't invite him
to my house for dinner he's not going to
date one of my daughters uh you know
personally we don't have to get along
but
his his policies for America I thought
were good if he was a Democrat I would I
would support him also because of his
policies but you you can't even talk
like that anymore because people are so
blinded by hatred and you know what I
disagreed with Trump is I thought he was
very divisive now you know a lot of
people say well he had to fight back
well he could have fought back a little
bit more diplomatically because it
starts from the top
you know when people see this division
on the top it bleeds down into have
these two forces that are just at odds
with each other all the time and I'm
seeing that now worse than ever
worse than ever there's so much division
in this country families are fighting
with one another over their political
beliefs it's just terrible and I think
we're on a course I don't it would take
somebody with a very very strong
personality and real leadership quality
somebody that has to be charismatic has
to be endearing has to be just that
special kind of person to try to and
really believe in bringing this country
together again and I just don't know if
that person exists
yeah that's going to be a difficult
person to to find
um even just somebody who wants to bring
the country together and doesn't think
that one part of the country
are full of demons
even just finding that person
yeah yeah that's going to be tricky
um okay going going back to your kind of
experience in the in the mob
did you learn did you learn anything
that you've passed on to your kids that
was that you found helpful from living
that life oh yeah I mean you know a lot
of things listen
in that life you you have to have
discipline
very very important you got to learn how
to respect and Obey Authority
it's kind of a it's almost like
militaristic in that way you know and I
think I was President I would have every
18 year old join the military for two
years I think it's it's great learning I
think it's good for our young men
especially you know to learn discipline
and authority and structure in their
lives so you know I've also learned in
that life that you become a good
listener you don't shoot your mouth off
you're very slow to speak very quick to
listen and I learned in that life that
um you should be the last one to condemn
somebody
because you know that life Michaela is
like a wheel and things turn around the
person that you condemn one day that's
on the bottom might be your boss on the
top and they don't they don't forget
that so you're always the last one to
condemn people
um you know to try to try to reason
things out first so that when your turn
comes you're not the first one that's
condemned so you know in these
equalities that I think are important in
life their life skills that I think are
very important you know I should tell
people especially in business you know
there's times when you could be the
smartest person in the room and you
don't want anybody to know that so what
do you do you keep your mouth shut and
you listen you let people talk and so on
and so forth and then and you learn a
lot by that you learn a lot about the
person you're sitting with and the deal
and the negotiation there's other times
when you're not the smartest person in
the room and people don't know that
because you're not you're not speaking
out of turn they're wondering what
you're thinking and meanwhile they're
talking and you're getting all these you
can become educated during that meeting
so you know I've taught my kids that and
and for the most part they've listened
to me and I have five daughters so so my
daughters are uh they're all very
dependent and they're uh you know they
like their mom they certainly think for
themselves and and their uh
um they're tough I gotta tell you
they're they're not pushovers they're
very tough that doesn't surprise they
instilled a little bit about it yeah
that doesn't surprise me that's very
cool
um did you have
kind of an us and them mentality you
said that you were in pre-med
and that you stopped doing pre-med right
so did you have a group of friends that
were kind of out completely outside of
this
um and then you ended up getting more
involved
is that kind of what happened getting
more involved back in the mob no I mean
not
yeah not really I mean you know I was an
athlete in school I mean I played Sports
I uh even though I knew about the life
and I was part of the life and I always
had my dad's friends around you know at
the house and all of that
um I was just fairly normal in my
relationships going to school you know I
had friends that way and of course they
knew who I was because my dad had so
much publicity so at times you know I
got into scuffles with kids when they'd
make remarks about my dad oh you got a
mafia dad you know I would fight but um
and then a lot of kids they lost your
dad you know kids are you never know
what they're gonna which side they're
gonna pick with you but
um so I was fairly normal things really
started when when my dad went to prison
and then I was really immersed in the
life when Joe Colombo who was the boss
of the Columbo family kind of took me
under his wing and then I was around the
guys all the time and then it meant
something to me uh because I had a goal
I wanted to help my dad so I started to
pay more attention to listen and to get
more involved
yep that makes sense
that makes sense I think I've I think
I've done a lot not to like compare us
at all but
um a lot of the way that I've structured
my life was to help my dad for whatever
reason and I guess I mean
well I mean lots of people know who he
is now so I guess he's an incredible
person but I always had like a deep
respect for my dad so a lot of what I've
done honestly probably since I got
healthy because when I was sick I was
that was basically what I did was just
being sick but when I got healthy I
think I've spent a lot of my time
um helping my dad for probably really
seven years like seven years basically
full time it's just been how do I make
this person's life easier because he
went through like Health struggles and
like Fame and controversy and it was
like how do I make his life easier
um luckily things seem to be set up I've
like structured things now enough that
it takes up less time but it's been an
interesting experience there's an is an
interesting experience do you have
siblings yeah I was one of seven also
um unfortunately two of my younger
sisters passed away so there's uh this
uh five of us left now wow um
and uh yeah so and we're fairly close I
mean they they all live back east
uh but we you know we stay in touch
is is there it was funny because it was
my it was my wife
it was my wife that really
um turned me on to Dad she was always
fascinated by she she listened to your
dad quite a bit uh and she was very
fascinated by his views on a lot of
things and she said Mike you got to
listen to you know Jordan and it was it
was fascinating really because she and
she still listens to your dad a lot
now we've got to get you guys to have a
conversation I told him we were on the
phone before I started the podcast and I
was like oh I'm talking to this guy
using the mob he turned his life around
it should be a really interesting
conversation it's like you guys should
you guys should talk that'd be good I
think people would really enjoy that
that'd be a good conversation yeah it
would be nice for one day one thing I
wanted to know
Are there women that are
in the more like business area of the
mob or is it really focused around men
in the families in America in cousin
austro which means this thing of ours in
closing Australia in America women don't
play a role in that life at all
um you know unless unless for some
reason you know one of the guys was
bringing their girlfriend or their wife
involvement in some way but they have no
Authority they have no place in that
life at all
uh it's different in Italy in the mafia
in Italy as a matter of fact I did a I
just did a
um
a video on my YouTube channel uh last
week about a woman who actually
um was kind of the boss of of one of the
mafia families in Naples which is my
hometown my parents Hometown
um so in Italy yes in the mafia here in
America no not till this point not
through for the last hundred years now
whether that changes or not I don't know
but I I doubt it will and is that kind
of the same you said you worked with
um Irish and Russians did they kind of
have a similar setup not that it was
a hundred percent men
um from the best of my knowledge it's
it's a hundred percent men
yeah I mean they did you know these
other groups didn't have the structure
that we had they didn't have the
formality that we had you know the
Russian mob I don't believe they take an
oath I don't believe they have ranks
they're more clannished to a family
actual Family Blood relatives that are
involved and it seems that the person
that's making the most money calls the
shots
um so they didn't have the structure
that we had the Irish people the same
way they would just you know gangsters
you know without a lot of structure
interesting and no women I I didn't
notice any women at all yeah okay
um I'm not that surprised by that
um was it stressful then for I mean it
must have been like I just I can't
imagine having to deal with life and
then also having to deal with the fact
that you're you're doing you're
operating illegally so you have to worry
about the government on top of
everything
um that must like is it stressful for
families Associated or was it stressful
for families Associated women associated
with the mafia yeah you know Michaela I
you know one thing I don't do I I never
glorify the life because it doesn't
deserve to be glorified but what I've
always said is that the Mob Life The
Gang life their evil Lifestyles and the
reason I say that I'm not calling the
guys evil because I was one of them and
and everybody's not evil now there was
some bad people but that's true in every
Walk of Life but the lifestyle is evil
because I don't know any family of any
made member of that life that hasn't
been totally destroyed and including my
own now not not my wife and kids
fortunately but my mother spent 33 years
without her husband
while my dad was incarcerated and in the
last years of her life she died in 2012.
I can only describe her relationship
with my dad is very ugly
because she blamed him for everything
that went wrong in her and what went
wrong well I had a sister that died of
an overdose of drugs at the age of 27 my
baby sister my brother was a drug addict
for 25 years he got himself in trouble
he was a street kid ended up cooperating
with the government and actually
cooperated against my father and put my
father back in prison when he was out on
parole a son against the father my
younger another younger sister she was
mentally unstable she died at the age of
42 of cancer
and so the whole family was devastated
and
any lifestyle that causes that for a
family is an evil lifestyle and that's
how it is across the board so it's what
I try to explain to these young kids
today I said you're not only doing this
to yourself you're destroying your
family this is very destructive it's a
bad lifestyle and and so yes it was very
very stressful my mother was constantly
under stress you know my sisters that
didn't accept it the way I was able to
accept it you know a little different
sometimes with the with a girl and a boy
and so
it's it's very hard it's a very hard
life to navigate and
um I I guess people get it you know they
look at it there from the outside
looking in uh but you know the
unfortunate thing Michaela with a lot of
young men
they're very very
um very impressioned By the Light
meaning I go into you know to these
gangbangers and they'll look at me and I
say Mike come on you had the cause you
had the women you had the power The
Prestige you had a Jet Plane they'll
watch the movie Goodfellas I don't know
if you ever saw that and else you know
they'll point out all the good things
and I'll have to ask them I said well
wait a second didn't you watch the
second and half of the movie the end of
the movie who died who went to prison
who lost everything who got killed you
didn't see that part they don't see that
they only see the first part who's got
all the money and they don't look at the
devastating end of the story
so that's why I discourage people all
the time and I you know I've worked very
hard with young people to try to
discourage them from that life and let
them get their lives turned around
obviously for me I don't know how you
turn your life around without a belief
in God I don't I don't know how you do
that but um so I try to steer people
that way but it's a tough very very
tough life it really is I don't know how
you would turn your life around without
a belief in God either I mean before so
I I didn't I didn't I was never an
atheist I was never a full-blown atheist
but I I never
I think I was so sick too like I was so
sick with joint Replacements and on so
much medication that I was like if God
exists like I hate him like this is all
this is awful and I can remember I think
when I was 17 I was 17 and I was
suicidal with like pain
and I can remember thinking there's like
there's definitely no God and if there
is one he's not good right
um
but now after I've been through all of
that and kind of and I'm thank thank God
I'm better
um I can also see what that did for me
right which is something that you can't
see when you're in it and so I don't
think of it the same way but I think uh
I think I would have a hard time
um with some of the things I struggled
with without
without a belief in God
part of it I think too taking care of
myself
like I think one of the things I
struggled with is I'm more inclined to
take care of people around me than to
take care of myself and I think a belief
in God has probably helped that
for whatever reason
because it's kind of I guess sinful in a
way to not take care of yourself right
and I don't think I would have viewed it
like that without a belief in God it's
like no I like I have to otherwise I'm
doing something wrong
yeah I get it you know it's uh it's the
age-old pro age-old question you know
why do bad things happen to good people
and when you don't have an understanding
um biblically on what God is all about
it's it's a very hard concept to
understand we have a loving and gracious
God and why do these bad things happen
to good people
and unless you have a real you know
understanding of scripture and and a
thorough understanding is it's a very
hard question to answer but as
Christians when you understand your
faith it becomes a lot more clear
um you said that when you were in prison
you read hundreds of books on different
faiths
which is very interesting so what what
was it about Christianity that made you
decide that was I guess the most logical
explanation for reality
well you know I I think it goes back to
Jesus you know what one of the things
that's very con um
and first of all you have to believe the
um authenticity of scripture
so I went back and did a study I had my
wife send me books on
authenticating scripture in the Bible
and there's so much evidence to prove
that the Bible is really authentic so
once I got past that and I said okay I
can trust this then I started to look
and I'm more of a new testament guy
and I really what was convincing to me
is the attitude of the Apostles after
Jesus died and to see how you know it
would have been a lot more normal for
them to run and hide
because their leader
um was gone and was killed in a violent
way I mean this is somebody that they
had all the faith in the world and then
they see him destroyed in front of them
and so what happens you know they leave
um that would have been normal but then
after Jesus resurrected and visited with
them they became like lions they became
strong they were willing to go to their
death and stand up for Jesus they
wouldn't even deny him at that that was
very powerful evidence to me and so what
I did was I researched
to try to convince myself one way or the
other that this is real or it isn't real
and I can't get into all of it but the
research that I did convinced me that
what happened to the apostles was real
that the history showed that this is
this was a real happening there really
was a resurrection the attitude and the
actions of the Apostles afterwards
proved to me that there was a risen
Jesus and
um it was all all of these things that
that combined you know I always tell
people I don't suggest that you go and
live in solitary for several years and
do the research like I did to prove you
know scripture but for me a life
changing and life-saving because it
became indelible and you know here's
another thing
um you know Michaela I try to look at
things very practically so from the time
I was five years old my father drummed
it into my head Michael you got to be a
man's man that's the standard in life
you have to live up to I heard it my
whole life when I got into the life the
same thing we're men above men We're Men
of Honor I heard that all the time so
when I started to study Jesus
I did things a little bit differently I
separated his manhood from his deity and
I really wanted to see what kind of man
he was because I was so in tune with the
qualities and characteristics of what a
man's man should be
so when I studied Jesus of Nazareth
I was blown away by his character his
strength his his
emotion everything about him to me was
was perfect and I said this is somebody
who should emulate so so trying to be
very practical about it I said okay
let's say I try to emulate Jesus of
Nazareth throughout my life well I'm
going to be a better person I'm going to
be a better husband to my wife a better
father to my children if I'm a boss I'm
going to treat my employees right if I'm
an employee I'm going to give my boss an
honest day's work everybody in the
community I'm going to be out giving I'm
going to be wanting help people they're
all going to benefit from me trying to
emulate what I perceived to be the gray
man that ever walked the Earth and I'm
going to benefit and then I said well
when I'm dead if he's not the savior of
the world well I'm dead anyway so what
did I have to lose I had nothing to lose
so I came to the conclusion that
emulating Jesus is a win-win situation
for any man and I actually teach that it
makes sense to men you can't lose
because you're from being the savior of
the world and are accepting Christ uh
and asking for forgiveness if we're
wrong about that well then we're dead
anyway we didn't we didn't lose anything
throughout our life but everybody
benefited from us being a better person
and
um but I do believe that he is the
savior of the world I believe it with
all my heart I'm not trying to justify
to convince myself otherwise I'm not a
perfect person in any way but my faith
is perfect because I believe this um and
nothing can stand in the way of that at
this point in time
I've come to the understanding of why
bad things happen to good people I get
it all you know my kids complain to me
sometime Michaela you know Daddy that's
not fair I said really you know it's not
fair what's not fair is this little
kid that was born in Africa that has
nothing to eat no shoes on his feet and
that child did nothing but be born
that's all he did so don't tell me
what's not fair because you got it
pretty good in your life and I
understand this you know and
it's helped me just it just helped me
throughout my life you know having this
point of view
and it's all because of my faith it all
because of the research in the study I
did and the impact that God has had on
my life that was great I think I think
that's similar to uh what my dad
believes and I'm not entirely sure
exactly where
he is in his journey I'm not like it's
hard to kind of get a read on that but
what I know he firmly believes is that
if you if you
um act as if Jesus would have acted then
your life is better and the people's
lives around you is better and so that's
what he tells people too is that's the
best way to live for sure and and and
everyone really who's familiar with
Christianity kind of knows that so
that's very that's very cool
um
Michael if people are interested in
learning more about you or finding you
online where should they go well my
website is Michael francis.com YouTube
just plug in Michael Francis I'm on all
the social media platforms you know
under my own name and usually it'll say
official next to us they know it's me uh
my book
um if they go on off your democracy.com
they'll get a free chapter we give them
a free chapter to see if they're
interested and then they can purchase it
anywhere on my website we give them a
sign copy of it
um I'm all over the place you know uh
easy to find but um uh yeah and you know
hopefully people tune in and you know
hear a little bit more well thank you I
really appreciate you coming on that was
great very interesting
well I appreciate you having me Michael
and I'm I'm glad that things are going
well and and uh you know I see you're
really growing too you know your subs
are really up there so it's it's great
to know yeah and I know we've been
through a lot and you know to see you
yeah to see you to see you come out you
know on on the other side of it is is
just great it's very rewarding you know
I've learned something and I think you
said something that kind of uh uh stuck
with me
um you know when you're focused on
yourself you know you got so many things
going on and you're trying to take care
of yourself and and and rightfully you
know it's like what that it's like you
know when you're an airplane and they
say you know if the oxygen comes down
put it first on yourself and then you
help everybody else you got to help
yourself first but I have found I I
really mean that is that it's it's so
much more rewarding to give of yourself
than it is to receive and one of the
things that motivates me is that I on a
daily basis you know between emails and
social media messages I get so many
messages from people that have been
inspired by my story by things that I
have to say and encouraged by it and
it's it's very motivating and it keeps
you going and it's just a wonderful
feeling it makes you know that hey
you're doing the right thing and so you
continue on so and I think you're
inspiring a lot of people I got great
comments wonderful comments
um when when you were on my YouTube
platform
um you know people saying how courageous
you were and just just wonderful
compliments so I yeah you're inspiring a
lot of people my daughters were like wow
you know
um and they don't listen to anything on
my YouTube channel but they listen to
you and and it was I was very glad wow
so they'll probably listen to this also
oh that's very cool okay well thank you
very much um I I really think what
you're doing is great too I mean having
actual experience doing
extremely serious things in a very manly
way right like it's it's harder to get
more manly than than the mafia right for
especially for people I guess who well
just in in general and so having that
experience and being in really scary
situations and then
and then talking about it honestly and
what you've learned from it
um and showing that you're like a family
man it's it's great I think it's really
good for people to see so I'm gonna try
and see if uh
I can get you to talk to my dad because
I'd like to watch that conversation I
think that would be good yeah that would
be great maybe the three of us even but
uh it would be great yeah I usually just
sit there quietly when he's involved
like even the podcast I'm releasing
today it was like I was kind of just
saying I was like I'll just listen is
that which which I'm totally fine with
those are like those are my favorites so
thank you again for coming on all right
Michael thank you God bless and uh just
keep doing what you're doing great